it is official the greatest prison break
movie since the Shawshank Redemption has
been brought to us by Disney Toy Story 3
ok so it has been 11 years since Toy
Story 2 hit the big screen and over a
decade later Toy Story has not lost it
at all
so Toy Story 3 starts out with this
action sequence that illustrates right
away that a kid's imagination can take
any toy and turn it into anything and
any human being alive can relate to that
and from there we see the Andy's all
grown up now and he's going off to
college so what's to become of his toys
they get donated to this daycare which
they think it's all great but I mean
have you seen the daycare apparently the
toys hadn't because they just had no
idea yeah they get their asses beat like
kids are ripping their arms off and
smacking them into it's like that
chaotic kid rampaging scene in
Kindergarten Cop where Arnold goes but
he's just not in Toy Story to do that so
the pain goes on and the bashed and
beaten up toys in this daycare either
the rabble of nameless victims or the
douchebag toys that rule over them at
night it's like prison no what can you
say Toy Story 3 like the other two has
comedic timing that is straight-up skill
like there are a few times in this movie
I just laughed out loud like there's one
scene with mr. Potato Head I couldn't
stop laughing and then the movie goes
from this touching movie about
separation anxiety to a prison break
movie believe it or not and it is
awesome
I mean excitement laughs this movie not
only has what you're looking for in a
summer movie but just a movie in general
it had it all what can I say I liked it
this movie felt straight up just like
way more epic than it should have felt
but it was epic yes it's a movie about
toys and teddy bears and the word that
I'm gonna choose to describe it is epic
I don't care I'm sticking to it it's
epic and the end scene of the movie is
really touching I'm not gonna lie it's
just really emotional shut up I'm
hardcore it was sad like Cameron Diaz
was saying that the end of Shrek Forever
After was really sad it was just a
really sad ending because everyone says
goodbye and it's the last one it's just
heartbreaking but I didn't feel that at
all the end of Toy Story 3 felt like
everything it should have felt like I
mean it was touching it was sad it felt
like the end of an era felt like you had
to let go - it's really good and it's
kind of weird for me I'm not gonna lie
cuz I haven't been fond of a lot of
movies this summer and the one I just
love happens to be about toys I would
feel strange if I felt that Toy Story
was meant for kids but it's really not
it's meant for everybody whether you are
one year old or a hundred and
seventy-eight you can connect with this
movie you'll laugh you'll love it it's
for you the only way he will not connect
with this movies if you hatched from an
egg and when you hatch from said egg you
were already an adult you missed out in
your entire childhood that or you're
Danny Bonaduce those are the only two
ways everyone else should watch this
movie now sorry I'm a little overzealous
but what can I say it's been a
disappointing movie summer and I just
saw a good movie that's enough to make
me smile Toy Story 3 is not only the
best movie of the summer so far but I'd
say it's probably the best movie of the
year so check it out you'll have a good
time but first if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more then
click here to see more
[Music]